Community Pride on Las Vegas now is
sponsored by Findlay automotive group
Southwest Medical part of Optum care
Silver State Schools Credit Union and
then V Energy it is always a good time
to discuss mental health and Stress
Awareness Rocky caught up with a
doctorate Southwest Medical the sponsors
of this segment to learn more
mental health and Stress Awareness
Italy nowadays that issue continues to
rise at all ages what are you seeing out
there
uh well thank you thank you for having
me and uh this is such a such an
important topic where we see um you know
mental health being talked about in the
news we see it in our friends family
members and you know unfortunately in
the last few years we've noticed
certainly an increase in the mental
health illnesses I'm here at the clinic
not just in Las Vegas but I think this
is happening all around the country and
again it's uh again because of a lot of
the a lot of the circumstances it's
becoming harder and harder to um cope
with a lot of these stressors that we
are that we experience nowadays which is
also adding to not the severity but also
more and more people are now
experiencing these mental health issues
for sure now what are some of the signs
that we should look out for in ourselves
and in our loved ones co-workers
but some of the key things to look out
for is uh in changes in your day-to-day
habits are you sleeping more are you
eating more are you sleeping less are
you eating less
um those are those are some of the
common things to look out for other
things to notice would be if you're
noticing that you have less energy to do
things that you things that you normally
like to do the other thing to also watch
out for is if you're using substances
like Alcohol Tobacco and Other Drugs
um if you use them
um frequently and now you're using a lot
more of these substances to cope with
the express that's also a sign that you
may be experiencing some some high
levels of mental distress or distress
trouble concentrating for example
whether you're in school or or at work
or just day-to-day social lives if
you're having trouble concentrating and
making decisions that's also another
sign
um and the other side would be if you
have chronic
um chronic medical conditions such as
high blood pressures diabetes for
example and if you are having trouble
maintaining
um good balance with your chronic
medical conditions that's also a sign
that you may be we end up going lots of
stress that needs to be addressed
some of the other signs would be
nightmares or if you're if you're having
trouble sleeping a feeling of fear anger
sadness being worried all the time
feeling numb
um emotionally numb and they're feeling
frustrated all the time those are also
some of the signs to look out for and
the last thing I would say is look at
some of the physical signs in the body
are you having symptoms like headaches
for example body aches all the time
stomach issues where the foods that you
used to be able to eat okay now all of a
sudden causing stomach issues skin
rashes is also another physical symptom
that you can look out for what are some
ways to manage that stress and anxiety
these techniques what we call them is
relaxation techniques what they do is
they counteract the negative effects
that stress has on the body such as high
blood pressures high blood sugars Etc
and these things include deep breathing
again I think we've all heard of deep
breathing exercises these actually are
very very very effective in managing
stress especially if you think you are
having a panic attack or if you are in a
situation that's very high anxiety
driven situation again try to step back
and start taking deep breaths and that
usually does help get over the anxiety
attack for the short for the short
duration but also doing deep breathing
exercises on a regular basis also does
have some long-term benefits in managing
your stress and anxiety and biofeedback
is a second technique again this is
something that you should discuss with
your uh with your primary care doctor or
perhaps your mental health specialist as
well the last thing I would mention is
progressive muscle relaxation again
making sure that we're doing some
meditation some mindfulness practices if
you are running into an issue where you
can get into your provider you can't
um you can't get help right away feel
free to call 988 um it is again One Stop
Shop and it's open 24 hours seven days a
week free and confidential and today
support again over 250 languages
we want to thank Southwest Medical for
being one of our community's pride
sponsors one